degrees made gay guys smoke and look
more manly than [ __ ] dudes pumping
gas
dude when they would they would pack a
cigarette dude yeah yeah yeah are you
calling them gay just because they were
dancing
doctor volta's not gay oh yeah
[Music]
is there anyone like the 420 Blaze It
hell yeah brother do you really yeah I
like taking Edibles every now and then
oh okay but you do you celebrate 420
like a holiday no I celebrate Hitler's
birthday though I just don't do this
well we're talking about fortunate of
the day I thought it was on at 4 20 P.M
every day or every day you do it every
day oh okay okay no not every day you
know actually this this 420 I didn't
partake I didn't do anything I just not
on purpose or anything I just kind of
forgot about you even watched Half Baked
or anything cool or no or watch chef
with John Favreau I like I like that
movie Chef I like his cooking show I
like his show Coach very good I like
cooking but I don't like the sweets I
don't like desserts so I just skip all
that you skip all that yeah I go to the
Savory when he makes pieces pizzas and
grilled cheeses yeah okay so President
Biden has announced Mass pardon for
federal marijuana possession it's about
time dude a step long stop by Advocates
and the most significant action on
marijuana his administration has taken
to date which was Zero until now uh he
also directed federal agencies to
conduct a review of whether marijuana
should remain these schedule one
substance
um people convicted of simple possession
will be pardoned that's honestly pretty
crazy the pardons will clear everyone
convict on federal charges of simple
possession since it first became a crime
the pardons will also extend to anyone
convicted under the District of Columbia
drug laws since the district is not a
state and charges in DC are technically
considered federal charges people a lot
of people don't know that but that's how
it is
possession of marijuana is a misdemeanor
punishable by up to one year in jail
minimum fine one thousand dollars at a
first conviction more than 6 500 people
were convicted of simple possession
between 1992 and 2021 so and thousands
more under DC code under Federal right
White House officials have said but the
vast majority of convictions happen at
the state level and the White House is
appealing to Governors to follow suit
issue the same pardon also state level
still doesn't have to follow those rules
right so California already is doing
that we're legalizing [ __ ] we're getting
out the marijuana cards events Beach
[ __ ] goddamn a decade right yeah but
pardoning people that like have been
convicted that's totally different thing
well right but federally was the whole
thing like so if you got caught going
across state lines you got caught like
going like from like in the airport with
marijuana it's a different thing yeah
like like once you're past the duty-free
section
oh it's Federal now so that means I
could trans I could take my marijuana
from one state to another state
all good well you are you are already
able to do that if the two states are
cool it's already cool but not exactly
because federally you could have got
popped that's the problem so so it used
to be my possession yes possession you
could get pop for federal a federal
offense right now that's done so like
now it's really just going back to the
States but it's also what's that athlete
that that is uh Brittany grimer yes but
that's a Russian that's different that's
Russian rules
Congress should pass a law saying and it
counts in Russia and then she'd be fine
right and accounts in Russia it's also
crazy that Biden's just taking out
people that Kamala is putting in jail
because that's what that was she was
known for whoa whoa whoa whoa
there's so many people in jail just for
possession of marijuana she's kind of a
dark dude
not what he meant
you know he he's a simple man he doesn't
know what he said what do you think
happens to all the criminals that let's
say you got popped for possession in
like 85 and you go to jail and then
while being in jail as a result of being
imprisoned you get into some [ __ ] to
survive in prison and you get your
sentence extended for the things you did
in jail
do they count all those extended time
[ __ ] I bet they go I bet they forget
because what if that spirals you into
like a prison lifestyle that you can't
[ __ ] get out of I know I want to hope
that they take them out too but they
probably don't all charges Beyond Simple
possession like distribution or
possession with intent to distribute are
not covered
so probably the things that resulted
from stuff that so nobody's getting
released from jail because of
um the pardons that isn't that isn't
anyone currently or there isn't anyone
currently in federal prisons solely for
simple possession there are thousands of
people who have prior Federal
convictions for marijuana possession who
may be denied employment housing or
educational opportunities this action
will help relieve the collateral
consequences arising from those
convictions okay so it's more like a
moving forward thing yes it moves the
federal government more in line with the
states because the states have already
basically ratified like the marijuana is
legal in 37 States right now marijuana
is legal uh 19 states have legal adult
use marijuana five states have
legalization on the ballot in November
so it's pretty much happening it's just
a process because we are a
representative Republic you can't just
federalize something and then all the
states have to ratify it that's not how
it [ __ ] works yeah so yeah it's it
takes and I have Schoolhouse Rock
explained it
hey give me a [ __ ] guitar I'll
explain it I'll do it right now plug me
in was there ever a moment when you guys
were younger that you uh did believe
that marijuana was like very much like a
schedule one level like this is I
thought it was the worst thing ever
after dare into thinking that they're
scared the [ __ ] out when I was in high
school I thought marijuana was like
heroin just the way like I saw like if
we if I got caught with weed and the
cops found weed on me and beat the [ __ ]
out of me and [ __ ] like that you're like
oh [ __ ] this shit's crazy yeah dude I
thought if I even got caught with a
doobie people would be [ __ ] my butt
in 15 minutes because like that's what
they teach you they're like you're going
to jail people can that's what they
teach you and dare yeah I kind of I
stayed away from marijuana until like
later in my life like when I was a kid
in high school I would smoke a little
bit but even then I was like so turned
off and scared from it because I was
like ah [ __ ] it can I ask how did the
dare people demonstrate drugs through
dance yeah interpretively they used to
have the three screens they would like
have these three screen presentations at
like in our high school our years and
they would just have like
just talking about like scenarios they
would play out scenarios of like Cody
got caught smoking pot look what
happened to him you know those kinds of
hey have you seen the Vape commercials
on Youtube and [ __ ] oh dude playing
football hey like vaping man people
think it's like sick it's actually
really not that sick
that's how it was with marijuana and
they and then what they say they go
there's no Vape in team that's what they
say what the [ __ ] they play out this
whole Sports thing where it's like a
quarterback and he's like vaping and
[ __ ] and he throws the football and the
receiver can't catch it because he's
like overthrowing him and he's like ah
[ __ ] this Vape is rude about life
they always cut the black and white and
the guy's like like Mom like what the
[ __ ] I'm just trying to vape a little
bit and she's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
I don't know if any of those things work
because I remember in when I was in
sixth grade like we had sane which is
kind of like dare I remember that and
then cops would come to talk about it
and you're like oh [ __ ] I don't know
this is gonna be so boring right and you
don't even listen then they would have
some new inmate come and then you're
like oh [ __ ] this guy's [ __ ] dope
tattoos man so it's like it doesn't even
fit can matter like what they're saying
is just the person that says it's true
yeah and the inmate guy would come and
then he would talk about how it's bad
for him like yeah it would be bad if you
already partied your [ __ ] life away I
need to like get to his level I'm gonna
party first and then tell the next
people don't do it what if he told the
cops he was gonna say what
the cops wanted him to say but he gets
into the classroom he's like yeah you
should smoke a bunch like just could you
imagine that's like this valedictorian
speeches yeah but but like that's his
like Leverage of getting out of prison
for a little bit yeah dude these
commercials are so trying Hardy they'll
get like a fireman he's like he's like
yeah I had third degree burners all over
my [ __ ] 75 of my body so you don't
think that's real he's like guess why
because the kid let it do and then
flicked it into a curtain
so that like has nothing to [ __ ] do
with marijuana
highly flammable situation
and wait and you're a fire party you
couldn't put it out that's just a fire
hazard
yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's just a match the OG ones was
like the girl melted in the couch
yeah I don't want to go anywhere I've
been ruining my life from smoking all
this pot and my dad looks kind of cool
yeah yeah I want to chill hard like I
can melt too man two OG ones I remember
was the eggs in the pan yeah the eggs in
the pan oh yeah and then the other one
was the one where the dad catches his
son smoking he's like where'd you learn
this and he goes I learned it from you
and the dad like has a moment of like
this is on patreon I'm telling you like
that was the problem with being a kid
who liked over easy though like this is
your brain this is your brain of drugs
I'm like that's goddamn my favorite kind
of egg
[Laughter]
give me some toast you guys remember
that a smoking commercial with that old
lady who had the [ __ ] hole oh yeah
yeah
so I didn't really know him how about
the white grandfather they're both white
what the [ __ ] you talking about I'm sure
why yeah he's Pure White don't take away
from him how do you think you make a
master race yeah thank you no so my uh
recessive gene my dad's dad was a chain
Smoker's whole life so I didn't meet him
actually because he died like well I met
him I guess I was like two years old but
I don't [ __ ] remember but like he had
that thing though in his tricky so like
he had the hole and it was like he said
it was like a computer or whatever it
was weird I was a hell of a dumb kid too
I remember seeing that commercial and be
like oh that's kind of cool yeah insane
smoking was the coolest [ __ ] ever though
yeah like growing up dude yeah watching
people smoke in movies it's James Dean
the campaign of making smoking cool was
so much more effective than making it
uncool like you didn't even have a
chance dude Greece made gay guys smoking
look more manly than [ __ ] dudes
pumping gas
dude when they would they would pack a
cigarette dude yeah yeah yeah are you
calling them gay just because they were
dancing what what doctor volta's not gay
oh yeah dude
bro come on he's not gay dude he's
allocated and Pulp Fiction was he gay
hey in [ __ ] Pelham one two three
there's no way a gay guy could play that
role his eyebrows
my ass is part of his game I will I will
say the the Marlboro commercials uh with
like you know just them being [ __ ]
Rodeo heads you know or Cowboy yeah dude
with horses kicking up dust and [ __ ] I
don't even remember seeing a cigarette
but just being like man I want a
cigarette I gotta yeah dude they were
really good at that [ __ ] scary and it's
funny to think remember when we were a
kid like the Surgeon General warning was
like hella fine print like Point [ __ ]
six foot that was like this big now it's
like 80 of the cartons like smoking
kills especially dude if you go to Asian
countries it's like the whole [ __ ]
carton is rap with like pictures of dead
people and you're like God damn can I
buy cigarettes can I just buy this have
you seen that yeah is that effective no
I think if you're already addicted at
that point I guess you're like [ __ ] it
right I do feel like I see less smokers
generally now but then like it's the
same using more Vapor you see you see
like overweight people when you go to
McDonald's it doesn't make you not want
to eat it yeah that's true super size
medium super size you made me go
straight to McDonald's honestly me too I
said there's no [ __ ] way what about
her honestly yeah even at the
restaurants right like you open the menu
and it's like oh this thing is 1300
calories like I don't care I'll take two
of them yeah yeah you're not allowed to
say that why you no yeah you're all fine
what is the most only fat bar can say
that what was the most effective
anti-smoking thing that actually kind of
worked seeing my dad [ __ ] cough up
lungs everything oh dude so it's almost
like a personal thing huh yeah and also
too it's just like you knew it was
[ __ ] bad for you there was just no
benefits well at least for from my
perspective my grandma smoked so much
that when she would send packages in the
mail to her family we could smell it on
the package I do miss the smell of
cigarette though you know like my dad
had this uh Chevelle and it would just
smell like cigarettes but the leather
seats I think it starts out smelling
like serious yeah like that is always
very nostalgic to me like the smell of a
[ __ ] cigarette I'm going to like oh
I'm gonna start smoking old Vegas that
smells old Vegas
come stay with me at the Commerce
tonight you guys
[ __ ] [ __ ] I remember the my first
girlfriend was a smoker and then the
first time we kissed which was my first
like real like making out kiss I could
taste it and I was like I don't think I
want my mouth to be like that this was
like ashtray yeah a little bit
did she survive
yes she survived yeah right
[Music]